When you're looking at that beautiful, dark night sky,...
...what goes through my mind is the wonder of it.
It's just so incredibly vast.
I never lose interest in it because it's just so beautiful.
I wanted others to enjoy the night sky as much as they could.
The best way to do that is to build your own planetarium.
This is the largest mechanically operated planetarium in the world.
All the stars are hand-painted...
...one dot at a time with glow-in-the-dark luminous paint.
It took about five months.
This is the only planetarium in the whole world...
...that has the night sky as glow-in-the-dark paint.
This is beyond normal,...
...but some of us actually put our dream into reality and do it,...
...and I took ordinary materials and I made something extraordinary out of them.